hey guys Pete here Game of Thrones
Season seven episode six has come and
gone at this point a lot of people saw
it early so those of you who waited a
lot of big stuff happened since a lot of
other channels already did recaps even
though the episode wasn't officially out
I thought I would talk about two of the
biggest things that I think happened in
this episode especially since it's such
a high energy episode with so many big
things happened I think these are two of
the most important things that will be
really interesting going forward with
the rest of the story of course I'm not
talking about Viserion being turned into
a white dragon this is that is something
that's been spoiled for me for a really
long time
it was pretty heart wrenching to watch
but I'm sure there's plenty of
conversation about that and there's been
a ton of debate about it leading up to
this and I can just tell you my own
experience of watching the scene like I
said it's been spoiled for me people
have been posting that in the comments
of my videos for close to a year now and
all the way up until the very last
moment I just sort of was fighting like
no it's not really going to happen
it became clear that it was probably
going to happen as people continued to
comment things like oh the leaks are all
real and everything else because things
were lining up but I didn't follow the
leaks I like I said I got spoiled on a
lot of it and I made a video about my
thoughts on the dragon because so many
people kept talking about it in my
perspective at the time was like I said
I just didn't believe what's going to
happen but anyways it's a big event but
the repercussions of that are pretty
clear and in the end of the day I think
that this probably is something that
george RR martin told them about i doubt
it'll go down like this in the books but
it really just evens things up a bit
it's not a huge game changer beyond just
the the idea that I guess so there still
has two dragons John's probably going to
become a dragon rider as well and we'll
talk more about that in the second thing
that I think was really important but
the first thing was Tyrians little
speech to Daenerys about a line of
succession now it's long been debated
that since the
and throwing probably isn't going to be
important in the end that there may be a
shift where a different kind of
government is put in place and most of
those theories revolve around Tyrians
input in that process so when he brought
that up in the episode it's a pretty big
deal the points he makes are valid she
goes into battle and she could die at
any time and as he pointed out as she
said she isn't able to have children he
says that the Nights Watch has a way of
choosing a successor and so does the
Ironborn despite their many flaws so
he's talking about an election more or
less maybe not exactly how we do it
nowadays in most of the civilized world
but it's a pretty interesting thought
considering what this story is about you
think about the big picture the stories
about all the squabbling and craziness
and insanity that people go through for
this power to sit on the throne and
that's what leads a lot of people to
look at it more as a unimportant ending
to the book Daenerys is talking about
breaking the wheel is in contradiction
with a regular line of secession in that
she would have an heir and then her heir
would rule and it would keep going like
that for as long as they were able to
stay there the idea that Tyrion is
putting out there is for apps people
will decide and that truly will make the
world a better place which in the
context of everything else is more of a
sensible way for things to end up now of
course no one makes it on the Iron
Throne
for a couple reasons but in the end I
think this is something to think about
how do they go from here to where they
end up how do they get this society to
let go of the idea that your name is
everything and your family history is
everything we'll just have to see how
that goes
now the second really big crazy thing
and these two things are probably more
interesting to me because they were
never spoiled by leaks because no one
knew about them
the second big thing was absolutely when
John kills the white Walker and the
other one the other whites who are bound
to it immediately fall that was a big
surprise because like I said no one had
known that prior to this episode airing
and it's pretty big in the sense that if
you kill the night king you have to
imagine that that's going to pretty much
decimate the entire army of the Dead now
there's a lot of thought about how that
all works and up until this was revealed
in the show my thought was that fire
whites and everything else aside the ice
whites the ones we've known since the
very beginning they were basically all
connected together so the night King
raised them or they were raised by that
magic and they all sort of functioned as
one big organism with a very simple
purpose like that's the most practical
way that I could think of you know like
he can't think for all of them so they
don't think they just do one thing and
they do it well and they're bound to a
hive mind or a collection if you will
when we saw this happen in the one sense
that would undermine everything like you
just have to kill one guy and then the
army falls what I think we should all
keep in mind though and Ford is is that
that means that this guy must be much
much harder to kill than just walking up
there and stabbing him now of course
people will go quickly into the comments
and post it has to be with Lightbringer
Azula as the temperature steel to create
Lightbringer yeah I mean that's one
possible scenario that that is a literal
prophecy that will come true exactly how
it is but it is like a thing because
this is going to end up shaping how they
attack and approach this war throughout
season eight they're going to be trying
to take this guy out they could take the
other White Walkers out one by one but
they really will never be able to win
unless they can kill him so it makes it
really interesting to me as to what he
can do having a dragon is a big deal
don't get me wrong I mean I don't like
the idea that happening
but like I said it was a compelling
scene and it was interesting to watch
and definitely felt sad and it will make
for some great special effects whenever
he rides it just like when Danny riders
and we'll eventually get some kind of a
battle but what's really a lot more
interesting to me is how do they end up
defeating this guy all together how do
they take him off the map because that
really will be the end of the war we got
some of a glimpse into a lot of stuff
that could be foreshadowing his
abilities and I'll make another video
about this this week that's what I've
been thinking about the most is what can
he actually do I mean he threw a javelin
a nice javelin like a dart into Viserion
didn't seem like a one-off event but
it's pretty freakin interesting that he
had those he could have thrown those and
killed everyone on that rock while they
were stuck there but instead he chose to
wait and he chose four to wait for a
period of time the obvious idea is he
the whole time was waiting for Dragon
and does that mean that he can proceed
what's going on does that mean he has an
equal ability to branch or does it mean
something else one way or another he
probably turned out that little scouting
party so that they could kill off the
one light Walker got the pieces on the
chessboard where he wanted and then he
waited for a dragon to come into the
picture and promptly removed it from the
board so I'm interested a lot and
thinking about what he can do and how he
can be defeated I want to hear your
thoughts in the comments one thing is
awesome at this point now is that we're
beyond the leaks I mean we have an idea
I guess of what is to come but not in
relation today this stuff because it
hadn't been written at the time of that
information being leaked out so all the
people that annoyingly posted that crap
all season long and all offseason this
is our chance for those of us who
haven't been talking about it to think
about what's going to go on in the
future so give it a like if you enjoy
the video check back all this week
because hopefully this next episode
come out early and we'll be able to have
proper amount of hype built up into the
lead up of it make sure you subscribe to
my channel and turn on notifications if
you haven't done that yet definitely
tell me your thoughts in the comments
following with me on Twitter you can
talk to me over there and my other
social media accounts thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one war that matters and
it is here